are you familiar with the great reset so
i i'm a
like kind of macro level like i haven't
dug into
each of it but certainly on a macro
level you just have this world economic
forum thing about how there's gonna be a
global reset of capitalism for
stakeholder capitalism and it's very
woke and we start seeing these things
happen in the united states with small
businesses
a lot of what i think you cover that's
why i ask because a lot of people have
suggested that the moves the government
was making
whether intentional or not greatly
benefited this this idea of a great
reset
yeah you wrote a book about the war on
small businesses
tell me what the government did and and
what happened to these small businesses
throughout the past year yes so we're on
small business so this
is the most underreported
infuriating story of the last 12 to 15
months and really
if you want to talk about it going back
decades but really in the last 12 to 15
months you had a government deciding
who was essential and who was
non-essential who was going to
thrive and who was going to fight to
survive and this was not
based on data this was not based on
science
this was based on political clout and
connections
and what that did and we talked a little
bit about it is it enabled
the greatest wealth transfer that we've
ever seen in history and the greatest
power transfer
you had seven technology companies in
2020
that gained collectively 3.4 trillion
dollars in value and seven companies
at the same time that you had main
street businesses by june of 2020
hamilton projects at 400 000 of them had
closed permanently
millions more struggling to survive oh
and by the way
it was a record year for initial public
offerings it was a
record year for spax which are special
purpose acquisition companies which are
highly
speculative investment vehicles that
only pop up in very frothy environments
where people are
trying to chase the old and you know
again there's this just
giant disconnect spenders or savers and
retirees
all getting thrown under the bus and
nobody
wants to talk about this nobody wants to
talk about this battle that's going on
and that has been sort of laid out for
us
over the last couple of decades as we've
moved away from capitalism to more
more towards central planning and then
the worst part about the whole thing is
that capitalism is the one that's
getting blamed for it
even though it was done by government
mandates and so
that's why uh as as i was approached to
kind of do
an economic debrief of on what was
happening during the pandemic
that the small business story just you
know had that line it was like so
important
but it was also just important in terms
of creating that through line
between decentralization and central
planning because that's what so many of
us
are fighting for if you're if it's not
small business it's crypto
it's the gig economy it's the creator
economy you know all these are trying to
to go you know in a decentralized manner
to to fight back
and have those free market tenants
against this consolidated power
and so it's really important for us to
all be aligned on that i want to ask you
about something that biden said
and uh he said in a really weird way but
okay
we got the story pay them more bizarre
moment biden whispers
and blames employers low wages for
worker shortages
that insists inflation will only be
temporary so there's two things here
this idea that the reason companies are
struggling to find
people to work for them is that they're
not paying well enough but we also know
that
the cdc just extended the eviction
moratorium which is in essence
free money for a lot of people there's
also the extended unemployment benefits
which is
literally free money for a lot of people
not that i'm suggesting these people
don't need that money
but it certainly creates an economic
pressure where
people are less inclined to work or go
seek out work
and so biden is making the the
accusation that it's the it's a small
business's fault or companies in general
for not paying more
i don't i mean so so basically so this
is this is all part of the plan
and i'll just ask you to keep this in
the back of your mind as we talk about
this
like if you were trying to kill small
businesses
if you were trying to only have a
handful of big businesses and you were
trying to get people more dependent
on the government through ubi those
kinds of things
would you do anything different than
what played out the last 12 to 15 months
without being just
a hundred percent obvious um so yeah i
mean you have the government
now in competition with the businesses
for employees and i'm all for paying
employees as much
as possible i think it's a good business
practice i think that you retain
better employees and more loyal but you
don't want to
legislate that because then you've got
16 year olds who are holding up a sign
that says come see the sandwich shop
we're getting paid 30
an hour when you could just stick that
you know in the side of the road
um there's an economic reason behind it
so
the fact that we have 9.3 million
jobs that we can't fill is because
central planners
didn't want you to be able to fill them
and they wanted people to be conditioned
to depend on the government but we know
that the only people who've ever gotten
wealthy being on the government dollar
are politicians
nobody ever gets wealthy on that on the
government dole it feels to me like this
is all part of the same
exact uh problem
i'll call it a problem right so you had
the the government shuts down in a
variety of fashions different
governments interesting shut down small
business
walmart target big box stores amazon
they're all open so they made what
was the number was it three trillion so
it wasn't necessary it was there were
seven tech
companies so you know google amazon
tesla
facebook whatever it was 3.4
trillion dollars in value two tiers to
that so like you said
they were open for business so the small
businesses that couldn't be open for
businesses saw their customers moving to
these big companies and
dollars going that way and then you had
the federal reserve pumping
in money to support the stock market so
the stock prices increased
so the value of those companies
increased as well so it was done
on two levels now think about the next
circumstance created by the government
not only are small businesses
competing with the government because
they're paying people but all of the
money
i should say for most of the money last
year went to these big massive box
stores
so who can afford to pay more when joe
biden says pay them more
okay well amazon's like you know we did
have you know massive profits last year
all right we'll increase wages that can
out compete the government
but that mom and pop coffee shop they
can't just manifest money out of nowhere
they can't compete and there's there's
no surprise that you know prior to this
you had saw you'd seen
amazon and some of the other big
companies start
pushing for a higher mandated minimum
wage
and the reason why they started pushing
for a higher mandated minimum wage
because they know it's anti-competitive
and they know what would drive
some of the smaller players out of
business and so
basically that's what's happening on a
de facto basis here is they're trying to
end around instead of legislating it
they're trying to do it by we're going
to interfere in the market we're going
to make it really difficult
for people to want to go back to work
we're going to compensate them for
staying home
and then we're going to force these
businesses who are
have been struggling they were shut down
by government mandate they were not
appropriately compensated for giving up
their property
for the public good under eminent domain
concepts under the constitution
then you just get back you've hung on
this whole time
and you can't find anybody to work and
and by the way
it's not even just low wages i've talked
to small businesses all over this
country
they're paying higher wages they're
offering bonuses
many of them can't even get people to
apply
so it's not even just like oh well you
need to raise the wage a couple dollars
because they've done that and they still
can't get people back
some have argued that this is the the
problem here is fulfillment
you know with with last year people
giving being given the opportunity
not to say flip burgers which i don't
think i don't think there's any lack of
dignity in being a burger flipper people
love burgers
but a lot of people they want more
fulfilling work and so the argument is
they're just choosing to avoid burger
king or mcdonald's or even
working at a coffee shop so so yes and
no so i do think there are a lot of
people who have the opportunity
for ones to pause and reflect and
actually make some decisions which i
think is
if there's any silver lining maybe
that's one of them
but if that were the case we wouldn't
have 9.3 million jobs
unfilled you would have the ones at the
higher levels getting filled and then
these other ones
not being fulfilled and that's not what
the data is coming back and telling us
nobody can find the jobs and it's not
just the burger flipper jobs it's a lot
of
mid-tier and and other jobs as well and
then the
the interesting part if you look at kind
of the data around wages
you're going to see well wages really
haven't increased
but the hidden sort of data behind that
is that a lot of boomers took the
opportunity to
to retire and to opt out of the
workforce so you have people who are
making
high five and six um figure salaries who
said you know what i'm going to retire
so those wages have now come out
and when you're computing the average
obviously that brings the average down
so even at if you look at the low end
those have gone up enormously but if you
look at it as just one
giant pie it looks like oh well wages
haven't moved at all
another another component too is um
these are the jobs we can see
when we when we see burger king putting
up a sign saying 500 sign-on bonus or a
thousand dollars
right what people don't realize is that
sourcing raw materials
and even manufacturing jobs a lot of
these a lot of these companies that you
don't
know even exist are struggling to find
people
uh then the inflation pieces you talked
you you had uh right
right let in with so that you have the
problem with not being able to find
people which is making it more
more costly but then trying to get the
raw materials and everything kind of
running through the the supply chain
and then obviously just having just an
enormous amount of money supply out
there all these things driving up prices
so again if you're the small business
you can't find somebody to work and
you've hung out to survive you also if
you're trying to
buy chicken because you make chicken
wings we saw you know was it buffalo
wild wings is now doing like the thighs
because i can't get the wings anymore
yeah i don't know if it's that
particular brand one of the major brands
has changed to thighs because they can't
get the wings anymore
we we here at tim cast love awesome
b-dubs we do we had an argument ian was
right
so is it so is this is this personally
devastating news for you then
i'm gonna flip this whole table over
and this is how this affects your life
people we're on small business
right here but actually it may be the
most important thing no no joke i mean
look going out to the bar watching a
game having wings and rings and whatever
else
you can't get that that's when people go
hey wait a minute
hold on you know when people hear like
it's hard to get a computer chip so
computers are more expensive
they might go i don't know actually
there was a survey done
they asked people which about certain
products and whether or not the cost had
increased
and airplane tickets and electronics
people were unsure of and didn't know
but chicken wings and gas were way up
and they knew it and bacon too
so this is interesting i think of all of
the things that can be taken away
because of government failures
that impact small businesses they really
have to be careful because if they start
affecting
bacon supply that would be yeah tragic
it right
it is silly to think like haha bacon but
no i mean people wake up and have eggs
and bacon people go to mcdonald's and
get sausage egg and bacon people eat
these things they enjoy them things the
reason it's a joke is because we know
that people really love this stuff
if they can't find it they start asking
questions people start getting mad
and that's what you got to get worried
if you're the government yeah i mean but
it's about so much more than that i mean
it really is about our
economic freedom i mean i think people
when they think about
business and you say like how many big
businesses are out there and
i do this with people all the time like
i'll hear like oh like i think there's
like probably like a million and it's
like
no there's 5 000 ish publicly traded
companies in the us
and there's like another five to seven
thousand maybe
maybe up to ten thousand but there's
like between ten and fifteen thousand
big businesses in the us
their before covid was thirty point two
million small businesses that account
for half the gdp and about half the
employment
so when we talk about this i think
people feel like this is like a niche
issue that doesn't really affect this is
a half the economy
and if you have to understand sort of
the thought process behind this
that if you are the government and
you're trying to usurp power which they
have done
in terms of how much they're spending
laws you know
purview everything else uh if you're
trying to deal
with people you're trying to get
reelected you're trying to get campaign
funds you're trying to push legislation
through whatever it
is what's easier to do like get like
10 000 big businesses behind you or 30.2
million small businesses behind you this
is a nuisance we heard the banks were
too big to fail
they did they did awful things that
ended up screwing up the economy for all
of our lives
and they got a bailout yet
they closed small business by mandate
and they got crumbs because
not only are they too small to matter
but they are too hard to control
and that is the intention here like you
cannot walk away from this you cannot go
through this
and think it's not not intentional and
by the way even if you don't the outcome
is still just as bad
but this is intentional is the intent to
just steal wealth from
middle class and working-class people it
it's to consolidate
power by any means what happens to those
people it
doesn't matter because they're not in
the club if you're not
in the club you don't matter you're just
like you're just pawns
in the in the game and so they have seen
that we have allowed them
to consolidate more and more power
i mean you have small businesses and
there are a couple of examples of small
business owners attilis jim
shelly luther and her salon alamo that i
talk about in the book
who said no you're not you're not gonna
take my property this is you're
infringing on my property rights and you
haven't compensated me for it
but a lot of people said okay
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you